saviez vous que selon le dr
et sondage de l'inpes institut national
de prévention et de santé est bien plus
de 70% des français citent le cancer
comme la maladie la plus grave
loin devant le sida ou les troubles
cardiaques aujourd'hui une femme sur
huit est impacté par le cancer du sein
et dans cette salle
combien de personnes ont été ou seront
impactés par le cancer quand on m'a
annoncé mon cancer en septembre 2016 je
me suis aussitôt plongé dans les
statistiques
combien de personnes survivent combien
de personnes récidive
je suis devenu incollable pourtant avant
cette annonce je menais une vie qu'on
peut qualifier de tout à fait normal
une vie de famille avec un mari deux
enfants pré ados un job que j'exerçais
depuis des années je pouvais manger tout
ce que je voulais sans me poser de
questions et je voyageais régulièrement
d'ailleurs nous étions prêts à nous
envoler en vacances je ne savais pas
encore et bien que cet examen passé en
fin de journée allait faire basculer ma
vie alors que je plaisantais j'entends
encore cette phrase madame asseyez vous
nous allons vous aider vous ne serez pas
seul comment que se passe-t-il tumeur
agressive et c'est un cancer impossible
les mots sont violents sans même les
prononcer d'ailleurs les médecins ne le
prononce pas aussitôt ce sont des images
noir qui me sont arrivées souffrance
altérations physiques gravité mort et
puis des questions à lège avoir assez de
force et d'énergie pour traverser cette
épreuve
quelle souffrance elle espère en dur et
à ma famille et à mon entourage
au delà de la violence de l'annonce pour
moi même j'ai dû affronter le regard des
autres avoir l'air malade isole et
stigmatise du jour au lendemain je me
sentais plus comme les autres je suis
devenue la mauvaise conscience des bien
portants en leur rappelant et bien que
nous sommes tous mortels
or personne n'a envie de voir parce que
tout le monde a peur selon une étude sur
la perception du cancer est bien plus de
50% des personnes interrogées se sentent
personnellement en danger et c'est pour
cette raison et bien qu'elle préfère ne
pas en entendre parler ou ne pas y
penser je comprends mieux comment
oublier certaines paroles en mai c'est
horrible c'est moi qui suis horrible ou
encore oh ma pauvre mais heureusement
toi tu est forte
allez on se tient au courant on se
rappelle et puis plus rien
moi aussi je suis passé par cette même
étape de peur j'étais submergé par la
terreur on se réveille le lendemain et
plusieurs jours encore après en se
disant quand j'ai fait un cauchemar
j'ai rêvé que j'avais un cancer comme
s'il fallait passer par cette phase
d'acceptation après la colère en fait
pourquoi moi personne n'a la réponse ni
le corps médical ni les thérapeutes
or on essaie tous de comprendre et on
comprend juste et bien que le cancer
n'arrive pas qu'aux autres
moi je considère que j'ai eu beaucoup de
chance dans mon malheur
alors comment aurais-je pu avoir la
chance alors que clairement la mort
rôder autour de moi et que du jour au
lendemain je me suis retrouvée noyée
noyé dans un océan de mots inconnus et
violent un nouvel univers celui la
maladie avec des traitements comme
chimiothérapie numérique tommy
radiothérapie immunothérapie
hormonothérapie
des mots qui riment tous avec maladie
mais moi je me suis dit que j'allais
faire rimer la maladie avec un retour à
la vie et même une nouvelle vie j'ai
très bien entendu qu'on allait m'envoyer
les secours qu'on allait m'aider mais je
me suis dit je vais pas attendre je vais
me trouver des rochers m'agripper me
fabriquer mon ado vous savez ce fameux
instinct de survie
et bien quand on a peur le cerveau peut
nous surprendre et quelques jours plus
tard
eh bien je suis passé en mode action
j'ai décidé de ne pas cacher cette
maladie j'ai également décidé bien que
j'allais guérir
j'ai donc décidé d'en parler et
d'assumer cette maladie qui est pourtant
très intime
on est tous d'accord beaucoup plus
facile de demander à quelqu'un alors
comment va ton dos plutôt que est alors
comment va-t-on st peut-être que si on
lançait en anglais est alors comment
vont tes boobs ça passerait mieux j'ai
pas personnellement ils vont très bien
et d'ailleurs ils sont toujours là je me
suis aussi dit et bien que j'allais
demander de l'aide
jal et constituer une équipe autour de
moi en mode projet des formations
professionnelles peut-être j'ai eu
beaucoup de chance d'avoir des amis mon
prof de tai chi les thérapeutes les
soins de support qui ont été là pour me
guider ma compagne est en fait savoir
demander de l'aide
c'est déjà une force et puis je me suis
dit que j'allais faire confiance au
corps médical
on parle de guérison vous savez ces
fameuses statistiques le taux de survie
à 5 ans est supérieure à 50% pour la
majorité des cancers et j'avais lu même
80% pour des cancers comme le mien alors
oui j'allais faire confiance mais pas
seulement
en fin de compte
les médecins ont qualifié ma rémission
complète d'extraordinaire avant même la
fin des traitements
je me rappelle très bien quand le
chirurgien m'a appelé un dimanche pour
m'annoncer qu'il restait plus aucune
cellule cancéreuse
je n'ai pas eu à subir cette ablation
pourtant annoncé étant redoutée
alors oui j'ai eu des traitements très
très lourd mais qui ont très bien
fonctionné et je réalise bien que j'ai
eu beaucoup moins d'effets secondaires
que ce qu'on m'avait annoncé mais mon
médecin de famille m'a demandé ce que
j'avais pu faire alors bien j'ai analysé
j'ai réfléchi
chaque épreuve est unique et il existe
mille et un chemin pour la traversée en
prenant conscience de tout ce que
j'avais pu faire
et bien moi j'ai identifié huit clé qui
m'ont permis à moi de construire mon
propre raddho et de traverser au mieux
le cancer je les ai découvertes
progressivement me transformant chaque
jour davantage et me rendant plus forte
j'imagine que vous connaissez tous le
sport sur ordonnance et bien moi je rêve
d'un coaching de la maladie sur
ordonnance oui je rêve du jour où elle
annonce d'une maladie grave ou d'un
cancer et bien on pourra proposer aux
patients dans le cadre du protocole de
soins et bien un coaching qui soient
spécifiques et adaptées selon la
pathologie oui c'est la première clé
cette première clé même c'est le pass
vip pour toutes les autres clés parce
que je réalise que j'ai été moi même
accompagné coach et que ce soit par des
amis des thérapeutes et même des coachs
pendant et après cette traversée
je pense que nous avons tous en nous
cette capacité à mobiliser nos forces
des guérisons en étant coach et comme
pour une épreuve sportive
finalement et bien j'ai pu gérer mon
énergie ma vitalité garder la forme et
continuer à bouger et même danser la
deuxième clé c'est de prendre soin de
soi de se faire accompagner par des
thérapeutes en bien-être et en donner
bien que j'allais faire des économies en
séance de coiffure et bien je me suis
déjà dépensé mon argent différemment
prenant soin de moi
et là j'ai découvert est bien une grande
palette de possibilités
spécialiste en massage nursing touch
compère de feu sophro le sophrologue
autohypnose socio-esthétique médecine
chinoise et j'en passe j'ai dû en tester
plus d'une vingtaine et croyez moi eh
bien ils ont été un véritable pilier à
la fois pour diminuer les effets
secondaires mais également pour m'aider
à rester féminine à me sentir en forme
et à garder le moral et je pense que
c'est vraiment important et bien d'aller
pousser la porte d'ateliers autour de
chez soi que ce soit dans les cliniques
les hôpitaux mais également dans des
associations conçoit accompagnant ou
patients d'ailleurs la troisième clé
c'est la connexion corps esprit il est
important de soigner le mental la
maladie qui veut dire pour moi le
maladie veut dire quelque chose pas
facile d'aller nettoyer des émotions
comme la colère la tristesse ou des vécu
parfois plus lourd
une vraie détox émotionnel je suis allé
voir du côté du décodage biologique et
j'ai trouvé quelques réponses
la quatrième clé c'est de continuer à
bouger
même si vous pouvez faire qu'une courte
distance s'en sortait marché peut-être
que marcher dans les bois n'a jamais
guéri personne mais ce qui est certain
c'est qu'aujourd'hui les prouver bien
que là le contact avec la nature a des
vertus incroyable sur le cerveau sur le
mental et même sur les défenses
immunitaires même chaud et bien je
sortais danser au risque de perdre ma
perruque sur une salsa endiablée sortent
également en extérieur quelle que soit
la météo pour mes cours de tai chi kong
et ça me faisait beaucoup de bien autre
clé l'alimentation
alors là ça ne s'est pas fait du jour au
lendemain telle une petite fille ou un
petit diablotin
et bien mes placards se sont transformés
au plus grand bonheur ou malheur
d'ailleurs bien de mon entourage
quand j'ai demandé à mon fils de 15 ans
de me trouver un petit exemple pour
illustrer ce cette clé il m'a répondu et
commun même franchement y'a rien de
drôle là dedans pourquoi parce que ce
changement c'est une vraie révolution
pas pour moi pour les autres je me suis
heurtée parfois à l'incompréhension de
l'entourage
pourtant de nombreuses études montrent
et bien il est vraiment indispensable
vient de changer son alimentation et de
ne pas nourrir les cellules malades ou
cancéreuses
en clair sucre le sucre blanc farine
raffinés ont disparu mon quotidien mais
également le lait de vache et bienvenue
aux laits végétaux
en clair tout ce qui est blanc j'ai
également compris et bien que l'option
raclette la veille d'une chimio c'était
une très mauvaise idée pour les effets
secondaires
je n'y croyais pas mais j'ai testé donc
l'autre option à savoir le jeune où les
jeunes
et figurez-vous bien que j'ai vu tout de
suite la différence sur les suivantes
autre clé ce sont les émotions positives
cultiver les émotions positives
la nouvelle devise d'ailleurs c'est
impossible est ce possible j'ai toujours
cru que j'allais m'en sortir et cet
enthousiasme est bien m'a beaucoup aidé
alors c'est vrai j'avais un bon capital
au départ mais j'ai cherché donc à
développer cet optimisme
ce s'entourer de personnes positives par
exemple
fuyez tous ceux qui ne croient pas dans
vos projets fuyez tout ce dont qui vous
parle de tati jacob qui est qui a
récidivé pour la énième fois et puis à
la place allez rire parce qu'on peut
rire même pendant un cancer et surtout
pendant 1 co cinquantenaire mon fils me
faisait beaucoup rire quand ils me
disaient allez maman sort prends ton sac
et tes cheveux on y va
j'ai également pratiqué le yoga du rire
je suis beaucoup sorti ça m'a fait
beaucoup de bien
j'ai également intégrer quelque chose
que j'ai découvert c'est la théorie des
3 kifs par jour alors pour ceux qui
connaissent pas bien je peux vous
assurer que nos journées même nos
journées les pires peuvent s'avérer les
plus kiffante alors oui j'ai été très
entouré tous ces sms ses appels ses
propositions de marche de sortie dead et
bien m'ont donné une force incroyable
parce que au lieu de me renvoyer leurs
peurs et bien il me renvoyait l'image
d'une crise telle forte courageuse
héroïque leur super woman comme il
disait pourtant tout le monde aurait
fait comme moi pour sauver sa peau et
des christelle j'en ai croisé des biens
plus héroïque
autre clé c'est le changement
en clair la maladie a mis un stop dans
ma vie nouvelle manière de penser
aujourd'hui on fait ça demain on verra
j'ai pu développer à mon avis un mental
d'acier une capacité à mieux profiter de
l'instant présent et à mieux gérer les
difficultés quotidiennes
du coup j'ai affiché sur mon linkedin
fighting cancer enfin surtout depuis
j'ai retrouvé un job parce que ça aussi
c'est un combat de plus amené ça m'a
pris plus d'un an pour rebondir
le chemin est long très long
en ce qui concerne le droit à l'oubli en
matière de job mais également de crédits
bancaires entre autres
on en prend pour dix ans alors vous
l'avez compris j'ai changé toute ma vie
j'ai changé de job j'ai changé le lieu
de vie de fonctionnement d'alimentation
mais j'ai gardé quand même tous mes amis
tous ceux qui ont le courage de moi
m'ont accompagné les meilleurs et ils
vous diront tous et bien qu'ils ont été
impactés également ils ont changé leur
regard sur le cancer leurs perceptions
et leurs vies également et parfois leur
alimentation
la dernière clé c'est la créativité
avoir des projets c'est un vrai levier
mon moteur à moi c'était la danse
j'allais danser une fois par semaine et
je me sentais vivante grâce à l'énergie
du groupe la musique les rires
et même si toutes les trois semaines je
perdais un peu plus de marc mobilité de
ma mémoire et de ma féminité
d'abord les cheveux les cils et sourcils
et puis la mobilité du bras après
l'opération
et bien ce que j'ai envie de retenir
c'est que après une bonne séance de
rééducation composé de kiné un bon
cocktail qui n'est marche nordique
paddle et bien je me suis retrouvé sur
scène pour un show de salsa anthony le
wonder woman avec un bras qui était
redevenu parfaitement opérationnel
quelques jours avant le mental est
incroyable en fait ce projet je le
visualiser sur plusieurs mois et il m'a
tenu tout au long et d'ailleurs je me
disais j'y serai le groupe d'ailleurs me
disent séduits sera aujourd'hui j'ai à
coeur d'accompagner de coacher des
personnes pour les aider à rebondir
après la maladie
je vais bien je vais très bien mieux
qu'avant
j'ai un job stimulant qui est temps qu
un accord avec mes valeurs
j'ai une multitude de projets personnels
et sportif qui m'anime
mais surtout je me sens libre une
puissante liberté intérieure
j'ai attrapé ce bonheur de vivre
vous savez quoi je compte pas le lâcher
c'est comme si j'avais trouvé ma
télécommande intérieur pour guider et
orienter ma vie et lorsque les peurs
ressurgissent parce que c'est pas
toujours facile
eh bien je me répète ce que nelson
mandela disait que vous que vos choix
soit le reflet de vos espoirs et non de
vos peurs
[Applaudissements]